A ton of death.
disappearing from the world view.
Seven years later, she started on her
path to redemption in Avengers the Children's Crusade.
Number nine, Scarlet was key in defeating
one of Marvel's all time greatest villains, Dr.
Doom in Avengers versus X-Men.
She joined The Avengers to take down the X-Men,
even helping eliminate the Phenix,
an ancient cosmic entity
Welcome back, everyone. It's Charlie.
This will be my video for the Scarlet Witch movie
that we just heard about this week.
Elizabeth Olsen has spoken
a lot about the future of the Scarlet Witch character,
what she wants to happen with her after she's done
taking a short break from the Marvel movies.
they're a couple major storylines that she's addressed.
So we'll break it all down.
That's why I attached that clip
to the beginning of this.
They're like a couple major Scarlet Witch comic
book stories that they haven't had time to do yet,
that they do plan on addressing
all of them are reconciling her redemption in the MCU.
Her children, Billy and Tommy,
her relationship with Magneto, the X-Men,
the other mutant characters,
all the other major characters like Dr.
Doom, people from her biggest comic book stories
Kevin Vega has also talked a lot in the past
about how important
the Scarlet Witch character is to the future of Marvel.
Elizabeth Olsen Primarily.
So she's going to be around for a long time.
a lot of what he was talking about gets into Marvel
Phase seven, like everything that they planned
after this soft Marvel reboot, Secret Wars,
all that stuff.
most of us.
Believing that has a lot to do
with X-Men crossovers in the future.
So just a lot of long term plans in general
for Elizabeth Olsen in the future of the MCU.
but she's done so many Marvel projects
back to back recently This is her talking about
taking like a quick break before she comes back
and does more stuff like, calling Kevin fire,
like, every day with ideas
is because I'm really proud of what we were able to do.
I think Wandavision was really surprising
And I really am just trying to figure out
how to load up other films and characters
so it becomes less about the marvel of it all.
says she does plan to come back eventually.
And because of a lot of trailers, a lot of stuff that's
been going on recently, we have a better idea for
what it's going to look like when they bring her back
and how they're going to redeem the character.
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're also doing the giveaway for the new Wandavision
Blu rays
The Loki Blu rays
They finally started releasing. And many thanks to Raid
Shadow Legends for sponsoring this week's giveaway
Raid is one of the biggest mobile games in the world
that's totally free to play.
This month raid is adding Xena warrior Princess
from the iconic nineties television series.
I was so surprised by this.
She has all her trademark weapons,
her sword, her whip, her chalk rum from the TV series.
within the game, her abilities
allow her to ignore enemy defenses and deal
way more damage to your enemies
depending on how they're buffed.
you can recruit her using the new champion
pass feature.
It's just like forge pass.
There are basic in elite versions.
Xena is the final reward for the elite champion pass.
You can also summon her from ancient
or sacred shards during the special summon boost.
Every week between November 10th And January 24th.
Next year.
In addition, they're giving away a ton of free stuff
using a bunch of different promo codes.
Brand new players can scan the QR code here
that I'll put in the video or the link
down in my description to get two free epic
heroes lite sworn from the Sacred order.
His kit allows you to keep your team alive
with an increased defense
both in a revive on death skill
and when you hit level 15.
Juliana a boss killer, also from the Sacred Order.
new players watching this can use the promo code
MonkeyKing to get the new legendary champion Sun
Wukong into epic champions, a rare champion warmaiden
using the promo code
raidwarmaiden for existing players.
You can also use the promo code.
IloveRaid to get a bunch of free stuff.
Do you not love free stuff?
So be sure to check it out and enjoy.
really important stuff though.
A lot of people asking
when is Scarlet Witch actually coming back?
Like she has to come back
before they can actually do a Scarlet Witch solo movie.
The current plan seems like they'll start teasing her
during the Agatha Coven of Chaos episodes
Halloween next year.
I just did a big trailer video for that,
so I'll link it at the end of this Joe Locke during
that trailer, footage is supposed to be playing
the adult version of her son Billy, a.k.a.
Wiccan.
There's a very twisty explanation
for how they're going to explain him coming back,
even though he was like a hex version of the character
in his soul, seemingly disappeared.
I get into the weeds a little bit more with that.
During the Agatha
Darkhold Diaries trailer video that I posted.
but they've got all kinds of young Avengers
related projects planned for Wickens character.
A big part of his story going forward,
though, is bringing back Scarlet Witch to the main MCU,
rescuing his mother soul.
Basically,
during the series, they're supposed to clarify exactly
what happened to Scarlet Witch during the Doctor.
Strange multiverse of Madness, ending basically
her chaos magic, Transfer her soul to the witches
road it alternate dimension that we see in this footage
here, that's where all the witches are walking
barefoot through.
is based on the more recent Scarlet Witch
comic book stories.
It's kind of like an alternate dimension
that her soul went to, kind of the way
they explain what happens to you
after you die during the Moon Night series.
Like your soldiers transfers to another dimension
based on your belief system.
during that series, they'll also address the aftermath
of scarlet, which is suppose to death, quote unquote.
Bill is supposed to start his own quest
to find her soul, return her to the MCU.
But but that's not going to culminate during the Agatha
Darkhold Diary series.
That's not going to happen to a little bit later.
his brother Tommy, a.k.a.
Speed, is not supposed to be in that series,
but he is supposed to return in adult form
in some other project.
they'll both come back in an eventual young Avengers
project like they did in the comics.
They teased that at the end of the Marvel's movie
with Kamala Khan. Ms..
Marvel
putting together a version of the MCU Young Avengers.
No idea when that young Avengers project is going to
happen, only that they're working on in the background.
So probably a couple of years
before we hear about that.
in the MCU, they'll loosely follow their comic book
backstory, where the two adult versions of her children
learn that their brothers learned
that Scarlet Witch is their mother,
and then both of them will try to rescue her
soul together.
this is where we get to the whole young Avengers
Children's Crusade storyline
that'll inform some of the Scarlet Witch
solo movie Eventually.
They're meant to be successful,
like they find their mother Scarlet,
which is supposed to be featured
during Avengers five or Avengers six.
So that storyline of her returning might culminate
during that Here's where we get to that Scarlet Witch
solo movie.
Now, they didn't say when they plan to release it,
but Jac Schaeffer, who did wandavision
Agatha Darkhold Diaries series,
she's featured in the trailer footage.
A whole bunch.
That's this person here.
She has three projects on her Marvel contract
right now.
the first two were Wandavision
and Agatha Darkhold Diaries.
The third is supposed to be that mystery
Scarlet Witch movie that we just heard about.
supposedly, that will be the culmination
of her redemption in the wake
of all of the messed up stuff she did going back
to Wandavision, like holding all those people in West
you hostage inside the hex for a week,
killing half of Kamar Taj most of Carthage
trying to kill Doctor Strange one American Chavez
killing the 838 universe Illuminati
almost killing 83
eight Scarlet Witch and stealing her children
lots of lots of messed up stuff for her to atone for in
largely the storyline that Elizabeth Olsen has spoken
about in the past mostly leans on Avengers
children's Crusade stuff,
mostly because she said her whole life
now is all about her children.
That's all she cares about in the multiverse.
She doesn't care about what's going on
with The Avengers.
She doesn't care about any of these new mutants
that are popping up all over the place.
At least yet.
She just wants to be with her children again,
which is a lot of the storyline
during Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness,
like she was trying to find her children,
but in a more aggressive, stabby kind of way.
so I think any storyline
they do for the Scarlet Witch solo
movie would just be MCU
adaptation of Children's Crusade.
Just a continuation of that idea.
Like her children, learn about her,
find her soul, and then she reunites with them,
and then they make it back to the MCU.
Eventually. no.
I say adaptation
because they always change stuff from the comics.
In the comic book version of Young of Andrew Children's
Crusade is way,
way more complicated, involves a ton of X-Men
characters like Core X-Men characters, Doctor Doom,
the Iron Lad version of Kang
because he's on the Young Avengers during that, there's
a lot of time travel that goes on during the story,
just stuff that they probably would not include
in the movie version,
because if they don't wait up
releasing The Scarlet Witch solo movie till after
Secret Wars, then by then they probably move way
past the Kang character.
Like they resolve that by the end of Avengers five.
end, they probably move past a lot of the time travel.
The multiverse more complicated storytelling tropes
that they've been using during this multiverse saga.
this just be a much simpler version
of the Children's Crusade with far fewer characters.
And as cool as it would be to see MCU Doctor Doom
show up in an MCU Scarlet Witch movie,
there's just so much stuff that they have to do
to introduce this character developing
before they could do the comic book young Avengers
Children's Crusade storyline,
I don't think that they're going to try and attempt
that.
I know a lot of people are asking what about white
vision showing up in a Scarlet Witch solo movie?
Elizabeth Olsen is basically said The Scarlet Witch
has emotionally moved past her vision's death.
Now, White vision is the original vision.
but the whole idea is that she's already made peace
with his death, at least in Elizabeth Olsen's mind.
And she doesn't think of white vision as her husband
or have any romantic feelings about him.
She just use him as a completely different person.
and I think by the time they get to Marvel Phase seven,
they'll have gotten past
all this big multiverse related stuff.
They'll have had some moment
where Scarlet Witch in Magneto
or on screen together
addressing their relationship in other universes.
there's still a way to explain
how Magneto could be her father secretly in the MCU.
But because Magneto doesn't exist in the MCU yet,
right now,
there's just a lot of twisty things
that would have to happen before they could explain it.
So which is easier to say that it's a multiverse
kind of thing.
Elizabeth Olsen has said personally
if she's going to meet Magneto on screen, though,
they're going to address the Magneto
Scarlet Witch relationship in the comics.
Quicksilver, too, that it would be the Ian McKellen
Magneto, not Michael Fassbender.
Just because when they're on screen together,
it makes a little more sense with their ages,
even though canonically Michael Fassbender is just
the younger version of Ian McKellen's
Magneto, same version.
So technically it shouldn't matter,
Ian McKellen is supposed to return in Deadpool
three is a different version of Magneto
from another universe,
but I don't think they're going
to get into any of the Scarlet Witch stuff.
During that movie, there were some reports
that they'd moved away from that.
just because they're already doing so much Wolverine
and classic X-Men stuff
and that is sort of like a Spider-Man No Way Home
for the X-Men movies like Deadpool, No Way Home.
but after Secret Wars or to this soft Marvel reboot
that they're doing, all that stuff is done.
Elizabeth Olsen has said that she would love
to do more crossovers with the X-Men characters
Also by that time, like Beyond Secret Wars,
they'd have had enough time to develop the Doctor Doom
character that then they could start actually
doing Scarlet Witch Doctor Doom crossovers.
Do the next real big plays
that we'll see Elizabeth Olsen come back is Scarlet
witch is actually in the what if season two episodes
but that's like a multiverse version of that character.
I believe she's coming back during the 1602 episode.
I will do episode videos for that as soon as they start
releasing them in a couple of weeks.
So be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss those.
Let me know in the comments what you want them to do
with Scarlet Witch in the future of the MCU.
Like which storylines
do you want them to include her in?
Congratulations Scott Ritchie 1278
You're the giveaway winner for my last big Marvel
video.
Please email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details.
Everyone click here for that new night Season
2 announcement and click here for that Scarlet Witch
Agatha Darkhold Diaries Trailer Video
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!